do you guys use dating apps like swiping
apps
yeah okay so on dating apps what
percentage of men do you swipe right on
when you're on a dating app
like super Sun
Nicole
um it used to be really like low uh and
then probably I'd say out of every
probably out of every like 10 men maybe
I I'd swipe on like one to two okay
should I I'd say like five percent Amber
you do guys that approach you right
okay
so that's really low right like that's
my point is that and those are just the
guys that are on dating apps that are
actually making an effort to download
and you know like make make contact and
put themselves out there the vast
majority of guys are mostly invisible to
you ladies so
right like you don't even see them
because they don't because they don't
meet your meet your qualifications
what would you say to those guys
what advice do you have for them
foreign yeah that are the 90 that don't
get your attention like what advice
would you give I think are we talking
about on like dating sites like swiping
no just in general because I think men
in general want to be in a relationship
with the women or a woman sorry
um I mean that's why we're here uh we're
not here to build skyscrapers and Roads
and computers and do podcasts and stuff
like we're here to connect with the
opposite sex and generally speaking have
children form a family sort of sort of
thing so
um I think that's what guys are mostly
looking for and they're making the
effort by going on dating apps so what
would you say to the guys that are
mostly invisible to you that are like
the 90 95 that you don't swipe right on
that don't even get the opportunity to
talk to you
so the Skype ratios for men and women on
dating apps is to clarify are about the
same at this point in 2023 so it's um
the the rate with the number of uh
people per 100 that are swiped by men
and women now at least is roughly the
same because I've done a lot of research
in this where did you get that data from
the internet everything on the
internet's true rich just Google it okay
um but anyway no
um no no the fact of the matter is no no
no no let's deal with this I actually
have a friend that that works at a high
level on a swiping app site okay
um so I have a lot more intimate
knowledge Beyond just what they publish
to the public I also have Insider
details on the meetings that they have
and the topics that they discuss but
um the vast majority of men never get a
match on a dating app right they get
really frustrated with it uh it it
doesn't allow any sort of connection
they have a very very difficult time and
most women on dating apps are uh
fighting for the top probably 15 to 20
percent of men probably 10 uh you know
they're fighting for ten or five maybe
yeah yeah it's very very low right so
you know if you're only swiping right on
those guys that you like like the good
looking guys which are based generally
on the first photograph you generally
don't swipe right on their bio or any of
those other things it's like what does
the first photograph look like quick
swipe good right most guys will will
swipe right on a whole bunch of stuff
and they'll never get matches so the
amount of swiping that happens is
probably pretty similar but the amount
of matches that men experience is very
very low it's right in the basement it's
it's not even close to women like
um there's guys
yeah it's like and it's a swamp it's a
swamp for women in a desert for men
that's a very yeah so to that point like
a very average looking woman like a four
or five can get hundreds of matches
within days whereas like an eight you
know that's a guy will struggle to get
like 25 matches right right because men
will sleep with women they say fours and
five so they swipe a lot so maybe that's
a problem with the men the men starting
their matching
do you not like men
I love men do you know I I love men uh I
do because I mean there's a lot of
points against sputtering with you know
whatever well men need to do this better
do you want me to sputter about women
too much better about women too well you
know we can go there too but I just want
to try to like understand why you want
men to do all of these things to meet
certain standards you know for you
because I mean like whenever we have
these conversations well you know men
need to do this or they need to be
better at that sort of thing so I'm just
curious about your experience with men
in the past I mean do not like them or
I love men and if you want to ask me
questions about women you know and our
responsibilities I'm happy to do that
too I I would I would love you because
I'm not a misogynist rich I'm not a
misogynist I'm not I don't
uh misandras is actually the sandras is
that what it is
apparently when men don't like women
miss Andrew oh okay okay
this is kind of the point I think this
is kind of the point that we're driving
at though it's what would you say to
those 90 95th percentile men or or the
people that are not getting attention
from women because
what you're seeing and being pushed in
the mainstream is is anything but a push
for positive masculinity it's we need to
shrink so women be can become more you
need to you know Place women on their
pedestal they need to be making more
money than you they need to be more
educated than you you need to sit down
and be quiet straight white man you've
had your time it's time for you to sit
down and be quiet and
and anytime I ask a woman what she's
looking for in a man it's never a guy
that just sits in the corner and allows
me to do whatever I want and agrees with
everything I say and never challenges me
on anything
so I think what we're doing is having a
really important conversation around
what's actually being pushed in the
mainstream and everywhere you look where
it's
it's never been a less
positive thing to be a man in in today's
society and I think that's what's
contributing to a lot of these guys that
are failing to meet expectations of
women and so
a lot of these guys and this is
complaining this is just kind of the way
I see it
a lot of guys out there just can't catch
a break
a lot of guys are being raised by single
mothers or they're being raised in
households with plugged in blue pilled
fathers and they're growing up in
everything they see on TV and reading
the news about how they're a villain
just by nature of being born and then
they're listening to advice on how to
get women and it's
basically be a worse version of a woman
and you'll get women and that's clearly
not happening so I think the question is
what do you say to these men you know
when we actually ask a woman on panels
like this what's the advice what do you
want to see from these men or what are
the things that you're seeing men do
that are turning you off and keeping
them invisible
what do you have as far as advice goes
for those guys that are trying to break
into that you know 20 percentile believe
it or not like I actually think that men
and women are better together than they
are apart right like a woman can be a
good compliment to a man's life and the
same thing you know the other way around
so I'm I'm trying to get some clarity
from the gals on the panel that you know
as your experience as women using dating
apps and dealing with men because you're
all single right now what advice would
you have for these guys
like they should be honest with the
female and beat themselves instead of
trying too hard because I have come
Encounter of guys that they
froze up we lost it okay
I don't know if she's gonna come back oh
no you froze up Jessica so back up like
five seconds and say that again you were
talking about honesty
yeah honestly I said that a guy should
be themselves
and not like just be yourself yeah be
yourself okay so we'll come back to that
in a second I don't think that's enough
to be completely honest you don't think
that's enough Amber so what else would
you call them do honestly I think it's
important to yeah be yourself great
whatever but what you have to provide
not just for yourself but for others I'm
not just talking about for a woman like
what do you have to provide to society
are you willing to help are you willing
to help anyone in general because any
guy that I've ever really dated he
has been really big in helping a society
helping non-profits very big and
providing for not just me but older
women single women helping like I just
think it's important to be a man that
wants to provide for other people and
stand up for your community show
yourself just be a [__] man like you
know what a man is I know what a man is
I don't think I gotta describe it we all
know what a man is okay
um so you went to you want a guy to
provide and to
um you know they tell men and women
different things right they tell men do
what's right and they tell women do
what's right for you girl
um but you're also the kind of gal
that's like well I make my own money so
I don't need a man right like I wanted
like I want to make sure that I'm not
financially reliant on a man but you're
also saying in the next breath that you
want a guy to provide so I'm a little
confused with that
I mean I'll be honest and then I usually
attract or men that want to provide I
don't really have to ask for anything I
don't ask thing but so like your only
fans is a backup then right it's just in
case he's not there or he's not able to
provide or he doesn't provide I mean
my main thing oh but if I'm with someone
and I love them like I don't I don't
know I mean I guess you could say so but
in general
I take care of myself I do what I have
to for the time being I mean if I'm with
someone
he wants to be with me and he wants to
provide for me he knows where I'm coming
from he knows what I do for a living he
knows that I do have a degree I'm not
stupid I'm an honor old student you can
look up my full name and I'm a mirror
scholar so I'm not dumb but it's hard
because some men just automatically
assume people in my realm don't know
anything but in reality it's not true
and I do attract very high profile then
I'm gonna come back in a second uh
should I what's your advice
I think Jessica was on the right track
about the honesty however I feel like
they need to be honest with themselves
so step back and say okay the dating
apps aren't working but I do want a
woman so what else can I do should I
start going to bars should I start
approaching them in person show off
confidence should I maybe take a year
off for yourself or you know so I think
you're definitely on the right track and
just you know it's time to be like okay
this isn't working now what
okay uh Nicole
if we're speaking specifically about
dating apps I would say well I don't
want to plug what I do here but I do
just in general in general okay I would
say for the dating app
um I think that actually men don't
present themselves as well as they could
on dating apps and I think that if they
understood how to present themselves
better online they would get more swipes
um because I what my experience is is
that there is a gap between generally
when I see a guy's profile a line and
meet him in person and I'm gen I'm
generally
pleased when I meet him in person and I
feel like oh you're you're your profile
didn't reflect that and it could use
Improvement and I think that that would
help and I have specifics on like what
they could do but I'll leave it at that
or general what are you know some
examples of some of the specifics it
sounds like you do this
I do
um so some of the things would be and
again before Rick tells me I'm just
harping on men I have things for women's
profiles too but since you're asking me
about men I would say first of all like
being the best like shape that you can
be in like be in good health like having
a healthy body
um keep keep up with your grooming like
if you're gonna have a beard trim it
groom it go to the gym go for a run do
these things to
you know just be your best self
externally uh when it comes to your
photos get your photos taken get good
photos they should be updated they
should be nice quality not blurry pay
attention to what you're wearing like
present yourself well and in your
prompts don't be generic like really
think about them and be thoughtful
um there's just a lot of things that you
can do but the photos are like a usually
the hot mess and men are not making
themselves look as attractive or
desirable as they are in real life in my
opinion so they should focus on that
so
based on what the gals have said and I
think Nicole you've probably given the
best uh advice to men that I've heard
from the bunch and I'll explain why in a
second but it's still [__]
um and I'll tell you why
um real quick I want to point out what
Shania said was you know roundabout way
basically saying become red pill
it's look around and figure out what
you're doing is it working and then go
looking for answers yeah and then that's
when guys find us but like
and then after they find you they find
the real way yeah sure which is the true
masculinity yeah yeah we'll get through
all those details but uh like you know
to Nicole's point she's you know she's
disqualified men because they've had
debt right and she's telling you know uh
guys that are struggling with dating
apps you know just have good photographs
and having good photographs is
definitely going to get you more matches
uh because you have to get your foot in
the door you have to get their attention
somehow I also heard just be yourself I
heard um you know a few other you know
pieces and points of advice which are
pretty typical that women generally give
guys and you know the reason why I asked
you ladies these points is because men
really really struggle with dating right
and they don't know what like you know
to Amber's point over here you know
she's talking about two guys that she
really likes and she's dating that she
thinks are top shelf men but Tristan
Tate DMS her overnight she's going to be
on a plane to Romania right away and
these guys will be ghosted right so it's
like
you know when when we have conversations
with guys you know I'm off and I talk
um it's it's around the topic of
developing yourself into the best man
that you can possibly be
um the reason why a large competent man
that is built like a fighter with lots
of money uh has good style is able to
get Amber to drop the two guys that
she's dating right now to go with him is
because of all those things yeah so
it it goes beyond just having a good
photograph it goes well beyond just be
yourself uh just be yourself is usually
like the advice that moms give their
sons is just be yourself and the right
girl will come along sort of thing and
that it's [__] because that's what a lot
of guys will do now they'll just be like
well myself is working you know a 30 000
a year job coming home smashing a frozen
pizza in the oven and uh getting stoned
and playing video games for 17 hours and
uh you know watching stream or twitch or
fortnite or something right like that's
a lot of guys angle for just being
themselves today and that's not enough
It's never enough right like you guys
have already uh shown us that it's not
enough because you've disqualified men
for quite a few reasons that don't meet
minimum standards I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out